hello
my name is philipp and i'm very happy to
be able to talk to you about
best practices for development and
operations of cloud composer
environments
and this way hopefully maximize the
benefits of using the product
my name is philipp knik and i'm a
product manager for cloud composer
part of the google cloud team
for those of you who are familiar with
apache airflow but not that familiar
with
cloud composer what you may need to
understand is that this is a fully
managed apache airflow product
with full compatibility to its open
source counterpart therefore
any dags or workflows you may want to
run with apache airflow
you can also run in cloud composer and
this way benefit
from a fully managed environment now
since this is a fully managed
environment there are some features that
distinguish it from a self-managed
apache airflow
and i would like to spend just a minute
to call these features
out so that we understand how they
differ and then we're going to dive
directly into the best practices for
development and operations of
environments when it comes to benefits
of a cloud composer environment first of
all
i would call out the deployment speed
you can get started with the product
very very quickly and practically in 20
minutes get an environment up and
running without having any prior
experience with apache airflow
and since this is a managed environment
what you're also
gaining is you don't is the fact that
you don't need to manage
your own patches or underlying
components and upgrade them as needed
and you also don't need to look into
reliability metrics and essentially
worry about having your product affected
by outages of underlying components this
is all taken care of
as a managed product the cost of using
cloud composer is predictable
and i would even argue it is well
optimized for use
what i mean by this is that it optimizes
for total cost of ownership and
therefore
the fact that you don't need to manage
individual components of the platform of
the architecture of the infrastructure
you're saving time that obviously can be
accounted for also from a cost
perspective
since this is a product fully compatible
with open source apache airflow
the code that you run in cloud composer
is fully portable
to its open source counterparts and
therefore you can freely move your dax
into cloud composer from apache air
floor and out obviously assuming we're
talking about the same versions
without a fear of being locked into a
specific platform or
specific product enterprise customers
will
specifically appreciate the fact that
cloud composer comes with multiple
security features that are available out
of the box and we're going to cover
some of them later on in today's
presentation but elements like
private ip or shared vpc or even network
perimeter
are supported out of the box by the
environment and you don't need to spend
time on configuring those
last but not least cloud composer as a
managed product also comes with
technical support so in case there is
any outage or issue that you may need to
have
some help with you can always refer to
google cloud support
asking for additional assistance
obviously that follows your agreements
with the technical support from google
cloud that you have in your organization
so without further ado let me dive into
development practices
that hopefully will maximize the benefit
and experience
from using cloud composer let me start
with a somewhat
pessimistic but actually optimistic
message which is that
every task can fail and while it may
sound
not that encouraging what i mean by this
is that in fact
you can and you should account for
potential failures
and build some measures into your dax
that recover from those issues and a
great example
is using a built-in retry policies that
can recover from issues for instance
network outages
and therefore get your dac properly
executed successfully completed
even if a particular task goes down
because of for instance a network issue
so always remember about building a
proper
retry policies directly from the very
beginning and it
shouldn't really be and after thought it
should be a part of our
regular development practices however
for
retries to work properly it is very
important
to have your tasks idempotent what i
mean by this
is ability to run a specific task
multiple times and expecting the exact
same result every time
now imagine that you are creating some
kind of an entry
in the database and you insert into
table using a command
and then you have to re-run the the same
task by doing so you may end up having
multiple
entries simply duplicated in the same
database table
that's probably not the best approach
and this task may not be idempotent as
such
and therefore a better way to handle the
exact same request is to for instance
insert or replace with a specific key
that
is assigned to this specific transaction
and therefore
if repeated will land in exactly the
same place in the database and worst
case will simply overwrite
the same entry and this way a particular
entry that inserts the data into the
database becomes idempotent
and works very well with a potential
retry mechanism
so always remember to use retry and
think about item potency of the tasks
that you're orchestrating with it
while developing airflow dax
it is very important to leave the work
that needs to be implemented and
executed as part of your workflow
for operators and tasks there is a
temptation to put
some logic some transformations outside
of the tasks and outside of operators
but the challenge with doing that
is that airflow doesn't really then have
a great visibility into those activities
and also can't really delegate this work
to individual workers
which is not ideal from end-to-end
management of your workflow logic
so the rule of the thumb should be to
have
your dac as a very simple and
streamlined piece of
code that delegates all of the work to
individual tasks that are implemented
using
proper operators speaking of operators
you will also likely need obviously as
part of the
airflow dax to interact with many other
products
and you may end up in a case where you
realize that you have never used a
particular integration before
and you want to start creating your own
operator or a sensor or a hook
to essentially connect to those external
systems
my hint on this specific scenario would
be to always look into whether there is
already an existing operator or
integration created for that specific
interface and try to use that the
community has put
tremendous amount of work and effort
into building operators
that are available for the most common
interfaces the most common products
and also protocols and this way enable a
broad usage of airflow
with orchestration of those different
products and services
so again instead of trying to write your
own operators always try to see if you
can use one of those that are already
there
and benefit from what the community has
done and if you need to create another
one
and you realize that somebody else may
benefit from it you may also consider
contributing it back to the
community while
creating your tags you will often get
into cases where
to properly implement your business
logic you need to be supported by
some modules that are delivered outside
of your
specific dac and typically you would
rely on
pi pi modules basically python modules
that extend the capability of your dac
and the best way to manage installation
of the pi pi modules
is through a built-in feature that is
available in cloud composer
so this feature allows you to define
which packages are necessary for
your individual dacs and they are being
installed in the environment as a
dependency for your dax and obviously
it makes them available right away for
your dax in their
execution one more hint i would like to
pass in here is to
avoid using a specific version if you
don't have to
and leaving it blank means you're more
future proof and you're not specifically
limiting yourself to a version that you
have
created and used at this particular
point in time so again
use the specific version only if you
really have to for particular reasons
there could be cases where you may want
to create a dag
that consists in fact of a hierarchy of
different dags
or is somewhat modular and this could be
to abstract a piece of work
and keep it as a contained piece of
logic that's
basically a bigger dag can interact with
and there is
frequently a question on how to best
deal with this scenario
should i use zapdax or some other way
and i would personally not recommend
using sub decks and the primary reason
is that there could be some operational
issues with doing that
uh deadlocks and many other scenarios
and as such
probably one of the best ways to handle
that specific case is to use
diagram operator instead and this way
from a particular task of attack
expose make a request to other dacs
and make them executed as part of your
core dac as we are seeing here in this
specific diagram
so again use diagram operator instead of
trying to use subducts if necessary
so these were the high level development
practices when it comes to coding of
your tags that i wanted to pass
but there's also a lot of hints and
recommendations i would like to share
when it comes to architecting your
composer environments or managing them
moving forward so let me start with
probably one of the most important items
that i would like to call out in this
space and that is
to upgrade your environments frequently
the airflow
community is putting tremendous amount
of work and effort
in improving the quality of the product
and shipping features that the community
will benefit from
staying up to date with the airflow
release
gives you access to all of those new
features and bug fixes that the
community has created
and the rule of the thumb is to not fall
behind more than six months from what
has been announced
or shared by the community and this way
not
falling behind basically the benefits
that those new
releases bring now since the upgrade
process itself can be somehow
heavy when it comes to effort there is a
feature in cloud composer that
addresses this challenge a little bit
and that is the upgrade feature that
allows you to upgrade an environment in
place
and prevents you or avoids the need for
creating a new environment
moving all of your decks over or for
instance even worse
losing the history of your dark runs so
again
use the upgrade feature to keep your
environment up to date
and stay with the recent version of
airflow to benefit from all the features
it brings
i also want to spend a moment talking
about security features because this is
important for multiple customers um and
obviously there's a lot of security
features you can choose from and i
highly encourage you to look into those
and pick the ones that are best suited
for your organization
and your individual needs the first one
i would like to call out is private ip
with private ip cloud composer
environments
the nodes that are being used for
compute of
cloud composer are not assigned public
ip addresses
so with that they can't really be
addressed or accessed from outside of
the vpc network
and as such are protected from a
networking perspective
from such access they still have access
to the outside world they can still
reach out to the internet but they
simply can't be accessed from the
outside
now when it comes to the web server
of cloud composer and user interface for
airflow
the primary protection mechanism and
security mechanism when accessing
this component is authentication so only
authenticated customers and users
have access to a specific airflow user
interface
however some customers want to have one
more layer of security
for the web server as well and that is a
network layer so if you want to have
network level protection for your
airflow user interface
you may want to use web server access
controls
that together with private ip make your
environment
not accessible from the outside world
unless
the caller belongs to a predefined and
white listed
set of ip addresses so this is like a
firewall
setting that secures access to your web
server from the outside world
which you can use to configure and
further tighten access to your
airflow web server another feature that
may be
used in conjunction with other
components is
vpc native mode which puts your composer
environment and specifically the gk
cluster that it uses
into a vpc that allows for access to
other components in the same vpc
customers that want to have ultimate
level of
network level protection may also want
to use a feature called vpc service
controls
what this feature gives is ability to
configure
a network service perimeter which
becomes
a standalone isolated network that
prevents access from the outside world
but also prevents access from within
the perimeter to the outside world
creating a totally
separated and isolated network and
services deployed into such network
perimeter are ultimately secured
from network access perspective this
setting
this architecture also comes with its
own challenges because for instance you
can't easily use
externally hosted pipeline packages
because this network
connection is not available anymore so
while it comes with additional
complexities to manage
it also comes with increased security so
some organizations may choose to use
this feature
to further secure their composer
environments
two more features i would like to call
out for composer are
shared vpc and domain restricted sharing
with sharedvpc
you can create a vpc that becomes a
central hub
that multiple projects connect to and
exchange information
with one another through that hub only
so this gives customers a central place
of management
for network traffic and control and as
such
if you create and deploy a composer
environment to one of those projects
participating in the shared vpc setup
you gain a lot of control over the
network
traffic originated from that composer
environment or coming into it
so this is something that some customers
may want to consider as well
and the last security feature i would
like to call out is domain restricted
sharing
and this feature allows customers to
restrict specific domain names that need
to be there
in the addresses of individual accounts
for access to the composer environment
and as such even if somebody has been
granted access to your environment
but does not belong to a whitelisted
domain which could be your
corporate domain name basically won't be
able to access your environment
um without proper domain name in their
email address
so this is something that customers can
also choose to further
secure their access to composer
environments
another feature that might be worth
considering is
integration with google secret manager
as a way to manage secrets for your dax
it is very frequently the case that when
managing integrations from airflow dax
to other systems
you need to use some keys or some
passwords
to connect to those external systems and
the question is how do you best manage
those secrets and keys
uh while doing so the recommended
approach from my side would be to use
google secret manager as a back-end for
managing such secrets
this integration has been introduced in
airflow 1.10.10 so you need to use that
version on your
um and has also been recently added to
cloud composer environments and this is
something i would highly recommend
for all the customers that need to use
secrets keys passwords
when integrating with external systems
this
recommendation or hint is almost obvious
to mention which is
to separate production from
non-production environment
and while it sounds obvious it is
important to call out that
as you create your production pipelines
that run your
business process and business logic you
need to have
a separate environment to test the newly
created dacs or changes to those decks
separately from it and that's
particularly important because
not only you need to have management
separation but you also need to have
well fold domain separation as well as
management separation and
um performance and capacity separation
so for all those reasons you should have
at least two environments one for
production one for other
use cases obviously you can end up with
multiple environments for different
stages of your life cycle depending on
how your organizations
implement that one more item i would
like to call out in here is to also use
cacd so as the deployment process of dax
requires you to place dax into the
environment you want to make sure that
you control how this flow works
and there's a lot of different ways you
can establish ci cd pipeline
that leads to a proper dac deployment we
don't have a single solution as part of
our product but we have recommendations
in our website that you may want to look
into
on how to do it again there is not a
single solution because there is not a
single architecture that customers
follow
but again i highly encourage you to look
into the documentation that we have that
may help you establish those cicd
pipelines
for your specific use cases and one more
thing to
add in this specific scenario is while
you're having your separate environments
for different stages
please ensure you're using the same
versions of airflow and also have the
same versions of
dependent pi pi modules as otherwise the
testing may not be reliable enough
once you develop all of your dacs you
need to ensure that they run
successfully in production and deliver
the right results
and to help in this specific need we
have
created a monitoring dashboard that is a
landing page for cloud composer
environments
and it consists of different charts and
metrics that you can
think of as three different layers of an
abstraction in a way
so the upper part which i'm going to
show in a second covers
statistics and data around the dog runs
the middle part covers airflow processes
and the health
of individual airflow components and the
bottom part
covers the infrastructure and for
instance metrics like cpu or memory
consumption
i'm not going to go through every single
chart that we're seeing here
what's really important is to learn how
to read those diagrams
and see the correlation between
different components that may occur
at the same point in time so for
instance imagine that we're seeing that
specific tasks started failing at a
point in time then we can look into
whether dag-bag size have changed
and for instance this failure that we
have just witnessed
may be coming from newly created and
newly deployed dacs into our environment
which actually if we then look into
airflow monitoring or even more so
infrastructure monitoring we can realize
that
while these new dacs have caused the cpu
of the infrastructure
to be maxed out and therefore lack of
resources is probably the reason for the
failure of the tasks
so correlating those different charts
and metrics together may help you
understand the story behind
particular issues or outages that you
might look into
obviously i'm not saying that the
monitoring dashboard is the only way of
troubleshooting
but it can be a helpful tool in trying
to understand
what might have gone wrong in some of
the dark executions
one more recommendation i would like to
pass at this point is to also establish
your own
monitoring alerts so that whenever
something goes wrong for instance you
have an unprecedented error ratio for
your dag runs
that you're notified about those cases
because nobody actually wants to be
looking into those
dashboards all the time we're not
currently shipping any standard set of
alerts because there's not a single
solution
on how to do it and how to get notified
but
since all of the metrics that you're
seeing in this dashboard are available
in the
stackdriver you can create alerts to get
notified about
particular challenges and i highly
encourage you to look into that feature
and use it as well obviously what's also
very important when it comes to
troubleshooting your environments is
looking into the logs monitoring is
obviously not everything
what's important and where composer also
helps
is by showing you all of the logs from
different components of the
infrastructure
in a single place so for instance as you
can see right now
i'm currently highlighting airflow
scheduler logs
and therefore if i want to look into
specific issues that scheduler might
have faced
or may have thrown as errors i can
easily see it in a single place
coming from different components of the
infrastructure so that's a handy tool
when it comes to troubleshooting
different issues in different places
of the composer and airflow environment
what is also very important when it
comes to ensuring that your dags run
successfully
is to scale your environment accordingly
and there are three components in the
infrastructure
that you can scale independently you can
scale the airflow compute layer which is
the gke cluster
and add more nodes as you need and
therefore get more capacity for
processing your dax for running your
workers for running your
tasks as part of your dax you can also
increase the size basically scale up an
airflow database
if you have dags that are particularly
effort intensive at a database layer
you may choose a larger database
instance and this way
have additional capacity at that layer
of the infrastructure and the last
component you may want to consider
scaling up is the airflow web server so
specifically if you have a lot of
different tags that the web server has
to process
or there's a lot of different users that
want to interact with it you may want to
create a slightly larger
web server to have the airflow ui with
more capacity as part of your
workload however what is very important
as well
when it comes to scaling of the airflow
web server is the next feature i want to
introduce
and that is enable dac serialization so
this is a feature that is currently
not a default of the airflow environment
or a composer environment it may become
one at some point
but today in the default approach to
implementation of airflow and composer
the web server is continuously
processing your dax
trying to understand what's inside and
how to visualize them and what these
darks are if you enable the acceleration
however
the airflow scheduler is taking one more
step one more responsibility and that is
to serialize the dax
and save the outcome of that
serialization into the database
from that point on the airflow web
server is actually reading the outcome
of that serialization
instead of going through a continuous
endless loop trying to
run your code as part of the web server
and this is a significant
reduction of the work that the web
server has to perform
and also as such it is significantly
reducing the needs for capacity of the
web server
and the risk of a potential instability
of the web server because it no longer
needs to run
any somewhat untrusted code as part of
the web server
so this is a feature i would highly
recommend to reduce the load of the web
server and increase the stability of the
entire system
so with that let me very quickly recap
all the items that we have gone through
very quickly today
as a way to hopefully help you manage
and implement
your dax in a way that give you the
biggest benefits
from using the product so again assume
that failures will happen and are likely
to happen even for
the best and the most reliable endpoints
and use
built-in retry and error handling
mechanism in airflow
and therefore make your dog runs not
vulnerable to those issues and
successful
practically all of the time to support
that also
make your tasks either important so that
they can be safely retried
without an unexpected consequences as
part of your dag executions
leave the work to the operators don't
try to put the code in between the tasks
between the operators
so that airflow can properly manage the
distribution of the work
and errors that may arise from it use
existing airflow integrations
all the operators hooks and
sensors that the community has created
it's a very long and comprehensive list
and very helpful in getting you started
with most of the systems around
take time to manage the python modules
ideally without specifying the versions
use the ones that are available already
upgrade your environment as frequently
as you can
and ideally don't exceed the window of 6
months without an upgrade because this
can render your environment as
outdated and lacking the recent bug
fixes and
improvements use built-in enterprise
security features since this is a long
list of potential features you may need
to choose the ones that fit your
organization and your
security policies and regulations but
look into those please and
choose once accordingly for managing of
your secrets
and keys with other systems highly
recommend to use
secret manager as a way to manage um
basically all of those
components that you need to have for
your integrations
use separate proton onboard environments
use ci cd
and ensure you're running the same
versions in all the environments with
the same packages
use composer's built-in monitoring
dashboard and logs
and if possible also establish and set
up your own
alerts so that you get notified on any
potential outages and issues that you
may encounter scale your environment
accordingly remembering that these are
three different elements that you can
scale independently the compute layer
the database layer and the web server
and then use the dac serialization to
reduce the load
of the web server and increase the
stability of the web server as a
component of the overall platform
with that i wanted to thank you very
much for attention i hope some of those
hints
were useful and i'm looking forward to
see you using cloud composer and
contributing also to apache airflow
community thank you very much